[Music]
everybody
hey friends what up Drex here from
drexfactor POI sharing with you the love
of poi spinning and flow Arts to benefit
your body and brain and today I'm going
to give you a peek inside of my February
playlist but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyre Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all of these awesome companies and
the work that they're doing to support
flow artists like yourself by checking
out the links that I have down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-business Friends of
the channel Lane machinski and Becca
becklinen thank you both so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission
so as I'm recording this it is February
6th I'm going to be traveling next week
so I figured I would get this video shot
early
um it is uh the first day in the 50s
that we've had here in DC and like a
week maybe a week and a half now so I
have been confined inside and I really
want to get out and move
um it is of course quite Breezy which
makes that a little bit more complicated
but heck with it you know I've I've had
some Cabin Fever it is also of course
semi-national day and I'm wearing my
Sunny flag hoodie that I got as a
Christmas present from my sister which
is awesome so the drill is going to be
exactly the same as it was last month
I'm going to be sharing with you five
songs that I have really really been
digging flowing out to lately and I want
you to vote on which one I will do a
full length flow video to at the end of
the month you can place your votes by
leaving a comment on this video saying
which song you'd like to hear me flow
out to and do bear in mind you can vote
for songs that I do not share in this
video video if you'd like to make a
request the trick is
the song that I flow to is going to be
the one that gets the most votes so if
you're trying to get something that is
not on the playlist then you're gonna
have to get your friends to also vote
for it so I'm going to actually start
things off with a song that narrowly
avoided being the song that got picked
last month which is the Black by VHS
collection I'm Still Loving it so uh
yeah maybe this month will be it's lucky
time
something but time nothing but time is
my fault foreign
so next up we have an entry from my
all-time favorite Canadian synth pop
band uh all comes crashing by Metric I
got to see them live a few weeks ago
here in Silver Spring Maryland and they
put on an amazing show I've Loved metric
for over a decade now the new album's
Fantastic this is one of my favorite
tracks on it foreign
[Music]
all right so this next one is holsters
By Night riots
um night riots they actually remind me
quite a lot of AFI the uh the the punk
and emo band
um they have some electronic elements
though so they have kind of a unique
sound I've already uh used a couple of
their songs in my monthly sponsored flow
videos and just every single time I get
suggested track of theirs on Apple music
I enjoy it so yeah this is holsters
now that I'm older
I see the way some things
[Music]
your reflection is
still crazy
[Music]
all right so next up we have When You
Were Mine by Night Terrors of 1927. I do
not know a lot about this band they have
a very long name but I do like the song
Alicia
all right so our final song for the
month of February is barely bleeding by
nothing nowhere uh it's got some really
beautiful soaring choruses and
um I think more than anything else I
just like I love the amount of intensity
and emotion in the lead singer's voice
in these choruses makes me think very
much of emo which I consider to be a
feature instead of a bug see what you
all think of it
foreign
[Music]
s five songs for you to vote on for this
particular month it is super Breezy
outside so I really really hope that the
audio came out from all of this
um yeah so let me know the song that
you'd like to see me flow to leave a
comment and let me know and this song
that gets the most comments is the one I
will flow out to at the end of the month
and if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like share
comment and subscribe to help other
people find it and to help my channel
grow
foreign
would not be possible we're not for the
kind support of all of these awesome
people right here these are my flow
patrons over on patreon they and the
people listed down in the description
help to make this video and all the
videos on this channel possible thank
you one and all for your very generous
supports and for you out there watching
if you would like to become a supporter
and you're not currently a supporter you
can become one by heading on over to
patreon.com drexfactor POI and signing
up there you can get access to a whole
host of awesome rewards and even better
you'll be helping me out in my mission
to bring POI spinning and flow Arts to
the whole wide world so go check that
out please and thank you if you'd like
to check out some of my other flow
videos I will leave a link to a playlist
of those down in the description as well
as up on screen if you're watching on
YouTube also the YouTube algorithm
thinks that you might like this top
video right here based on your past
viewing habits so maybe give that a
look-see as well hope the weather is
nice wherever you happen to be make sure
to get out and flow today and I'll see
you with a brand new video very soon
peace